[Music]  the motorsport has always always been  about technology advancement so you can  class me in the same as space or more  you get huge technology leaps when you  start to have competition focus was a  great environment for that what you see  here is an autonomous racing car so  we're using that to develop Road  relevant technology that you'll see on  the cars in the future  so everything from the radar the lidar  the sonar manned machine vision cameras  GPS inertial the compute infrastructure  is all the foundation for the teams to  compete with software and it becomes a  software challenge of that point that  we're talking about AI drivers of the  future artificial intelligent drivers  and one of these drivers need to do in  order to compete and in order to be safe  on the road  [Music]